welcome back to my Noland series I
brought on my good friend Matt Brando
you may remember him from my alien 3
review we did together I'm back nice to
have you thank you very much for joining
us
you got insomnia right here you got the
book right here you got your hot Boyz
kylo Ren you got your books over here of
your favorite books some terrible
looking figure I think you and I both
feel pretty similarly about insomnia
yeah maybe we both rewatched it and I
used to feel like it was really good and
I always like insomnia but I rewatched
it recently it just really hit me how
great this movie actually is saying I
sat down I couldn't really find any
flaws no I don't think I did either I
think I had one issue with the film it
was Hilary Swank
I felt like she was maybe a little bit
of the link but that was kind of her
character to be like nagging and
persistent and she's a such a fantastic
actor that she just fucking nailed it
and I was like no and then adding in
like the really great plot elements of
the whole backstory that and that shit
just really hit me and then especially
now I'm like kind of tired now and I
watched it before I came here like two
hours before camera and that moment at
the end where she's a cop through the
nine-millimeter bullet away and it goes
no don't be like that which we'll talk
about you know I'm just like everything
is just so and I almost cried almost
cried in a moment and I'd agree with you
it's like it was like true 210 attended
it's freaking amazing the plot of
insomnia is we have a cops played by Al
Pacino is going to Alaska to investigate
a murder of a young girl and we
eventually learned that she might be
linked into something with Robin
Williams who's a local author and it's
not just about a murder investigation
though it's a really personal story
because he's dealing with something that
he did possibly by accident maybe by not
know when they're searching for who they
think is the killer he's in this
environment filled with fog and he can't
see and he shoots his partner and his
partner dies and so for the rest of the
movie he is constantly making up excuses
trying to cover his tracks while also
trying to solve this mystery plus he's
in a town where the Sun doesn't set this
time of year and so he's not getting any
sleep
and that entire plot is so ripe with
tension and drama I wish I could come up
with something like that like that is
just such a great thriller plot yeah
it's really great how many layers
it really is that's probably why we
probably thought maybe earlier like
because I think I first saw this when I
was a teenager how about you yeah yeah
it was like maybe 17 or 16 yeah they're
on there for me as well so I think it
like momento and then like maybe this
one but there's so many like layers and
like story elements that I agree with
you guys like it's almost like a dying
dark go thing for me like I love dying
dark so so much and I think it's an
inspiration yeah it's just like this
film but it's so damn great it's like
damn I'm so depressed I can't write
something as good as that that's that's
always the struggle whenever I see
movies like this in like am because it's
really not an overly complex plot
there's just a few really great puzzle
pieces yeah that lead to something
that's really dramatic I have my own
theory about why I think of song it's
pretty underrated I'm curious if you
feel there's a reason why people often
say this is no one's worst movie what
yes it's commonly referred to as his
worst movie not a bad movie but just his
worst to film a lot of people do refer
to insomnia as his lesser film and in
fact on IMDB I think it actually is his
lowest rated film has like a 7.2 I think
his next lowest is maybe following but
it was a watch following yeah I don't
know I think it's his lowest rated Omaha
what the fuck yeah I don't get it I
don't get that either do you have a
reason can I have a fear home no I don't
I can't think of why I can't either
I feel like a lot of people didn't see
insomnia at first well but they saw
Batman Begins and memento and then maybe
they went oh my god this Nolan guy let's
watch his filmography and they get to
insomnia and yeah it's not a dark night
you know it's not a Batman Begins it's
not a memento it doesn't have like a
groundbreaking different original style
to it it was just a really great crime
thriller yeah like a lot of people judge
it too harshly based on his other films
because for me this movie is one of his
best like I actually I love memento I
think it's a really original movie
thing like it but I mean there are days
where I'd rather watch insomnia just
because of how brilliant the
storytelling is and Alba Chino is so
damn good in this movie oh yeah
absolutely
he makes it look easy oh yeah he doesn't
he doesn't make any effort yeah you know
it's great it's a great thing because I
was wondering if he did like a Dustin
Hoffman Marathon Man Thing because once
he starts getting the insomnia stuff
he's all like just fantastic acting he's
all like what and then a really
underrated thing about this film is the
editing like there's so many like little
like click like quick cuts of shit when
he's like he's seeing things or not just
that but some of the action it's just
like that it's most underrated like
editing like everyone off who's
nominated for anything or but it was
just like wow why aren't people talking
about these things and Pacino and like
you're saying early about all the story
elements it's just everything comes
together with the acting and the writing
and we just talked about Dark Knight I
do want to say something we'll talk
about Rob Williams
I think his character Finch and Pacino's
character was a dormer mm-hmm their
interplay in exchange their their
physical fights and their mental jabs
back and forth it reminded me why he did
like a Dark Knight type thing because it
remind me a lot like The Dark Knight and
derogation see I'm going that I'm going
back and forth that the boat and also
you can see why he likes Michael Mann so
much because I thought yeah it was up
there's some elements from some Michael
Mann films in there I don't know why
people shit on this movie I don't even
that makes no I don't I don't think
people should hold if you critics
critics love that it's got a very high
percentage on Rotten Tomatoes but but it
is kind of commonly referred to as as
worst movie which again I've never heard
that most people like it yeah it's kind
of like you know picking your least
favorite best friend you know it's like
okay well I like all of you but this
one's my least favorite on me that's
weird
you mentioned the edging and when I
rewatched it there's a sequence that
it's almost like you wouldn't really
plan it ahead of time because when I
make short short films or feature films
and we make films together in our free
time I usually plan out every shot
really meticulously I think he'd do the
same thing yeah when I was watching the
fog sequence where he is trying to get
his footing when he's really deep in the
fog right before he shoots his partner
it's basically just a lot of shots of
like his feet
tripping some quick close-ups of his
face as he looks around and then point
of view shots of the fog and it's edited
together so well to give you this sense
of like you can't comprehend what you're
seeing you feel like you're him if
something Nolan does really well he did
it with memento he made you feel like
you had that memory condition that
Leonard has in lamento bike breaking up
the footage the way he did in that movie
and insomnia you you begin to feel like
my god I need some sleep because as the
film continues and he gets less and less
sleep and he's trying to cover the
blinds with pillows and he's getting
flashback inserts of his past yes and
he's starting to see his dead partner
everywhere and he said he has that look
was just wow like we were like wow it's
so funny
great and you mentioned comparisons with
the way the Joker and Batman faced off
in the Dark Knight I thought the same
thing during the interrogation sequence
and insomnia where he gets in his face
and he pushes that chair back and he's
like you had sex with her didn't you he
starts asking him all these really
personal questions and everyone's like
what the fuck is wrong with this guy why
is he doing you need to take a break
again to pray and he runs near like
hover up you have an idea you get these
great inserts of somebody wiping
something and the way he cuts it in the
opening titles
Nolan is you think that's the killer
absolutely and then you find out it's
him yeah it's crazy and I love how he's
just at his breaking point
when he talks to Maura Tierney I think
as the actors name and he's like I asked
you I just asked you own your opinion
just two people talking I just want your
opinion it's so great that is actually
one of my favorite moments in the film
it's where it takes it from like what we
said previously from like a good great -
like whoa holy shit masterpiece
because it goes from like this movie
we're watching to kind of like something
more like kind of a real moment and she
says like the greatest shit ever she's
like there's two kinds of people who
live here
Laska wherever towns was there's the
people that are born here or people that
escaped from something I was a holy shit
I got goose bumps I like my neck I think
too great line goes on and we don't
really know what she's there for but she
saw me can actually tell his character
who actually talked to and asked rather
than someone's going to judge him yeah
and then it goes on to him arcing that's
pretty much a part of setup and start
with him actually arcing and saying hey
I did this shit and I will take the
blame and I'm going to keep using this
word but Robin Williams is so underrated
in this movie this came out in 2002
seniors one-hour photo another really
dark performance so he had a lot of
critical acclaim in o2 for being someone
who could really stretch as an actor and
really have a lot of range you feel his
presence in this movie throughout the
first like 45 minutes he's not in the
movie that much until that point and his
reveal is actually kind of astonishing
and I almost wish that I didn't know he
was in this movie that he wasn't even
credited that would never happen no
unless you're watching seven alba Shino
is in his apartment and he's looking
around and then you hear him outside the
door and it just cuts to a white of
Robin Williams like yeah he stared the
door he's like someone's in there yeah
hey his runs off I'm like fuck there's
like the greatest reveal like it was I'm
over the top like pan up his legs to
Robin Williams
yeah it wasn't like that at all yeah I
loved it I loved him in this movie their
interplay as characters is so great
because Williams seems to have this
suspicion that by murdering this girl he
didn't do it on purpose and you can tell
there's something a little off there
yeah he's weird this is one of the
reasons why I love it so much is because
it's not just bad guy good guy like
fight and chase each other you know it
wasn't just like that it was they both
have a really fucked-up connection they
both feel like they did something by
accident one of them is just a little
more morally in the right than the other
yeah
he's trying to cover it up which is
wrong and it may have been an accident
but they both sort of have to help each
other now and I've never seen that in a
movie either
we should mention this as a remake which
I have not seen the original I guess you
have yeah I have it's been like well six
or eight years but I remember watching
it I think I saw an old one first and I
was like a little room I got to see the
original yeah I don't know I'm better
okay so I like the 2002 versions did you
mean to shoot happen I don't know
anymore
hey and sometimes just really fucking
excellent is that he's so like
vulnerable and like exhausted in Hilary
Swank's characters like you you shot
what the partners name I forget a day
and and he's like it's like what you did
next day is like I don't know anymore I
was like holy fuck that's something he's
coming to fruition that man he can make
it maybe subconsciously he did on
purpose but he doesn't know and he's
becoming he's arcing and then she goes
back and her character
oh she's about to throw out that
9-millimeter but he stops her and her
like whole like existence in the film is
actually pretty important yeah the whole
movie I like every cycle on this movie
there were a couple times where she was
just maybe not quite as good as Pacino
in a scene which is not really something
you can really blame her for yeah but
your Winona County award then she she's
got two Academy Awards don't cry and
Million Dollar Baby Dean yeah she's
great in this movie really all the
acting is good I liked how the police
team didn't feel like a movie police
team they were all just very like normal
guys they're real yeah very
one of the biggest confrontations in the
movie is very subtle it's between
4-channel and the one cop who clearly
doesn't want them there the moustache
guy yeah every time so the two thumbs
yeah yeah and a blowjob who has two
thumbs in like blowjobs
sorry in tax Hillary Swank yeah yeah
there's all these scenes where Pacino
has a way of doing things and he's just
like okay whatever we'll do it you can
tell he doesn't want to do the things
like Pacino doesn't Pacino comes in
there and basically within a couple
hours figuring out all these other
things that no one else did I really
loved also his phone call to the
internal affairs asshole about his
investigation but he takes the phone but
not too far away from the actors an
injured loved person working the desk
and also writing wise kind of sets up
why she'll trust him and why he'll ask
her the question later and they kind of
have this connection now so I really
like how they do present a realism like
the guys they all do the fact Olga Chuck
I think his name one for the police
station when they're like Pacino and his
partner first come in like he was doing
very real in their interaction with each
other and like why they're here and
stuff and so you're I agree aren't 10%
yeah it was it wasn't like um you know
exactly I don't understand why this
movie gets a lot of the criticism that
it gets from people today because every
time I watch it which I would say is
maybe like once every couple years then
I watch it like every year it's got to
be one of those great really great films
like collateral exactly and heat
you can't watch like once or a month or
once every couple months you don't like
maybe one a year once every two years or
three years ago if they're so great you
can't you do it over and over again yeah
space it out yeah it's interesting I was
watching the the blu-ray special
features and I completely agree with you
by the way about that were you watching
and there was this interview with no one
at Pacino and Pacino and start talking
about how they didn't really have time
to do rehearsing for this movie and so I
guess they were on a pretty tight
schedule and then Pacino talked about
rehearsing in general and he was
basically talking about how he's like
rehearsing is basically just making
yourself feel comfortable with your
other actors really that's true and I
can tell that he has a really great way
of working on sets and with with
building a character because he never
looks like he's trying he's not a
try-hard actor sometimes he can get
really big and a scene obviously and
bursts out with some amazing moment like
every Machino movie has that moment
where he just flips out on somebody
really subtly and this one has it too
this with us where they're talking about
something and his partner after his
partner just really pissed him off
saying he's going to go to internal
affairs and talk to him about some shit
the partner acts like he's concerned
about something but you know just turns
and goes what do you care yeah like oh
shit no I don't want this turning up in
some courtroom six months from now and
my reps and the shit and pulling apart
on my cases come on will is bullshit
fuck you care like there's a whole movie
he's just like a straight edge yeah yeah
first half-hour of the movie oh fuck do
you care oh wow
that's Pacino and it works though every
movies got to have that one she got a
great ass helmet every end this is that
movies no different well me studying the
method as acting and him being a method
actor the method is all about the
appearance of the first time or
something like this illusion of the
first time so a lot of method actors
don't rehearse so they can give that
illusion up sometimes we don't even like
to rehearse in our own rooms we just
read the lines and we were in the
character's head and once we interact
with these people we don't like because
well if we do it over and over again and
we don't have a script with us it's kind
of fake right we want to give that
fakeness off so like in heat Pacino De
Niro didn't rehearse for their diner
scene because it'd be more real so it's
not just a time constraint thing it
might be also a technique thing as I'm
away him and you mentioned that he's
seen that amazing diner scene that
everyone loves from heat the scene on
the ferry felt like that yeah that's why
I said it's a very Michael Mann and yeah
he's filmography potentially it was like
these two guys are meeting and now
they're now we get to see them in this
scene and it the movie built to that so
much yeah and getting them there and
just hearing their conversation and then
seeing where it goes where Williams is
like look we're on the same page we can
help each other yeah or you know we
could just ruin our lives and do this
and then and you intersect long as
lingers on Pacino space where he's like
yeah holy there's like that bar here
he's like what do you want me to do and
then it starts that's like yeah the
progression of his downfall even more
it's such a great mind fuck the way that
Robert Williams character Finch's messes
with them and he tries to mess with them
back it's just a drawing of interplay
and there's something like it pisses me
off I heard for the longest time I need
to hear your take on this I hear oh
really can sue me or some semantics in
the song because rubber loses funny guy
every type of King Spanish want to laugh
well my opinion on that is that's
bullshit
except I agree I mean I think actors
have proven over the years comedic
actors in particular are amazing at
doing roles outside of comedy because I
think comedy is maybe the hardest
laughing is a really visceral reaction
like you can get someone to feel fear
through manipulation of a film score or
sound effects or editing or editing to
get someone to laugh you really have to
understand how to convey that incredibly
visceral reaction that we would get from
something that maybe because I think
laughter is almost what people are most
hardened by that in crying when you're a
comedian at that level that Robin
Williams had been at when he was still
alive recipes he was able to do a lot of
things with comedy that blew people away
but when he transitioned in movies like
awakenings
and Good Will Hunting he often proved
that he's a fantastic dramatic actor
absolutely but then later like with
one-hour photo and insomnia and some
movies like the night listener which
wasn't that great he was able to show
that he could do that darker side as
well and yeah I buy every minute up
absolutely i 100% totally disagree with
any yeah I don't know why it was I don't
want to think that man you were saying
about earlier about like the first 45
ish minutes of him and his introduction
of stuff the shit that he has on the
phone it's so awesome and I one of my
favorite moments also from the film is
when Pacino's in the fucking police
station and he gets the call from Finch
and they talked like a couple minutes
and he hangs up and he doesn't tell
anybody and it just goes off and does
his own thing and he's kind of ahead of
the game that's why the mustache man
hates them so much because he didn't
tell them about this all stuff that was
going down
it's just Rob Williams fucking nailed it
like I don't know what the hell these
people are thinking all they know just
want to laugh like this that was pretty
fucking creepy problem the best villains
in like the past how many fuckin years
released for me he was awesome he was
great one of my favorite scenes in the
movie is when Pacino first visits the
school and drags that kid out of class
and pulls the desk closer and he has
that amazing dialogue with him back and
forth you
this whole thing you do and it was fuck
the world act now that might work with
you mama
it might even work with a couple of
these local cops have known you long
enough to figure you're too dumb ever to
kill anyone without leaving a couple of
witnesses and a signed confession you
could work with me that scene to me is
everything I want out of a Pacino movie
I want that subtlety I want that tension
I want that intimidation factor that he
is so excellent at delivering honestly
insomnia is one of my favorite Nolan
movies I don't like it as much as the
Batman films or man I really love
memento but insomnia is pretty close for
me with in regards to memento I I think
it's super underrated and I honestly
thought for a long time about it because
so many people have said it's like his
worst go I can't find a flaw in this
movie something that bugged me something
out of place the performances are
perfectly on point as you said the
editing is really good and underrated
the music is great David Julian who also
did score for memento the writing is
really great one of the few times that
Nolan has directed a screenplay that he
didn't write really all in all insomnia
is one of my favorite crime thrillers
and I'm going to give insomnia and hey
flash I loved that scene as well it's
command that's why it's a Pacino like
just he's done it for so many fucking
years and this like brat essentially and
he's just like listen kid like I've been
through the block and it's fucking
perfect and the way that kid you can
tell if that kid was like this is Al
Pacino yeah not got his eye and it was
just a fantastic scene that builds up
the whole movie and it arcs and honestly
of watching it two hours ago if I wasn't
such a big Batman Salem I would put
insomnia over Dark Knight as the best
Nolan film so I don't know why some
people think it's the worst one and I'll
give it 10/10 I also like the Dark
Knight more in Batman Begins it's not
like they'd ever known movie but I do
think it is his most underrated and yeah
I hope that more people watch this movie
I'm sure a lot of people have that more
people who maybe skip this because it
didn't sound that interesting
or didn't sound that amazing or sci-fi
heavy or big actions yeah I hope more
people do check it out yeah it's very
underrated because the characters like
really pay attention to story folks next
time well you'll really appreciate don't
be like oh where does the bully like I
just said yeah I agree hard percent well
thanks for coming on man I appreciate it
definitely check out Matt's channel
please subscribe to his channel it is
terrific and I think you want to do more
film videos too
yes arrival we're doing a quick analysis
of the first act okay yeah so I may
actually get this up right here so I got
a by one of these guys I just you see
the collection this guy has it yeah
it's unhealthy no I'll think well thanks
man so thank you very much for watching
look forward to the review of the
prestige coming very soon as well as
Dunkirk after that let's hope that's
really good you guys are the best thank
you very much as always and if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes and done yeah
[Music]